speaking of his fans though this
happened recently at one of Matt's shows
watch this and she has wanted you to
figure
out
oh yo can we get a paramedic real quick
paramedic please you okay oh she's going
to cry you all right you feeling okay
you promise can we get a picture with
you yeah of course just don't use it for
the obiter wear my
God
best what happened
um well she uh she she's okay she's fine
which is why the joke is funny oh of
course of course no we wouldn't have
continued the show happen like somebody
get her out of here I got to plug merch
no no no I no
this
C that's aming am this was probably 25
minutes into one of our our headlining
shows and I hear this commotion and I
look down like I could see she's she's
convulsing so I I immediately once I
recognized what was happening I called
for anybody being a paramedic in the
room and luckily the people of the venue
and people who do work in the medical
field that were in in the audience rush
to her side immediately I have to leave
the stage when that happens so I can be
informed as to what's going on while
she's getting tended to properly and not
in anybody's way and it was like seven
or eight minutes later I would say my
security came back and was like hey she
she wants to stay and I was like I'll
give her a refund like she doesn't have
to stay
but she I went out there I was like let
me just go talk to her make sure she's
all right and I walked out and the first
thing I said I was like are you okay and
she was like yeah can I have a picture I
was like yeah no
flash she had epilepsy what a wild thing
to ask first man but you go you got to
you got you got to respect the passion
you know she wanted to stay she had to
you know com comedy makes people happy
you make people happy make people laugh
I forgot this and I went to a show here
recently in New York and it made me feel
so good to get out and just laugh with
other people absolutely you have no idea
it brings people together to such an
extreme level you think it's just random
jokes that you're just telling to make
people happy we're all Con in a
different way yeah absolutely she was
such a good sport about
[Music]
[Applause]
everything thank you guys y'all have a
great night going
home